here's my thing we talking about pets
there's only two pets like I just said a
dog and a cat
everything else is nonsense nonsense
people that got snakes get out of my
face if you got a little tarantula
aquarium get out of my face lizards
iguanas uh you know people that got like
rats and hamsters and all this kind of
stuff get out of here that's not a pet
the big one is people that got fish
tanks a fish tank is basically a rock
bath that's what it is it's an expensive
ass rock bath I had no a friend of mine
a couple they always fussing with a fish
tank always like oh man we just got this
new Coral it's like eight hundred
dollars what so you bought a 800 rock
that you keep it in a bathtub